[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Picasso'nun
1937 yılında çizmiş olduğu güvenlika
tablosu ile sizleri tanıştırmak isterim
tabloyu bilenleriniz vardır hikayesi çok
ilginç Bununla birlikte ilk başta böyle
bakıldığında çok fazla bir şey Anlamak
mümkün değil uzun yıllar bu tablo çok
konuşuldu hala konuşulmaya da devam
ediyor
tablonun böyle en ortasında bulunan atın
varlığı sağ tarafta bir tane boğa var
orada ne işe yarıyor yukarıda bir ışık
var o figür Neden oraya konulmuş hepsini
Aslında teker teker incelediğimizde
bütüne hizmet etmeye başlıyor Ama genel
itibariyle bir kaotik ortamdan
bahsedebiliriz
Picasso bu resmi çizerken altında yatan
güçlü bir nedene dayandı yani güvenliko
tablosunu ortaya çıkartırken çok güçlü
bir nedeni vardı ki hangi Neden onu
harekete geçirdi neden bu tabloyu ortaya
çıkardı neden bu kadar özendi bunu
sizlerle Bu konuşmanın sonunda
paylaşacağım o bildiğimiz tek bir gerçek
var ki eğer hayatımızda yaptığımız işle
ilgili güçlü bir nedene sahipsek
yaptığımız işi daha çok sahiplenmeye
başlıyoruz Örneğin bugün buraya gelirken
bu konferansa gelirken güçlü bir
nedenimiz varsa daha iyi Takip ediyoruz
daha iyi dinliyoruz Bundan tam 7 sene
önce Burdur'da bir seminer için
motivasyon Seminer için bir firma sahibi
beyaz eşya markası beni davet etti
seminere 2 saat var ama 2 saat böyle bir
boş geçmesin diye hocam Gelir misin İşte
çalışanlarımızla bir sohbet etsek
tanışmanızı çok isterim dedi Hay hay
dedim o günde yataktan böyle çok mutlu
kalkmışım firmanın içerisinde dolaşırken
böyle ilk kişiye böyle bir gülümseyerek
elimi uzattım merhaba dedim nasılsınız
dedim ki burada sizden de küçük bir
ricam var şöyle sağınızdaki sonunuzdaki
herhangi bir kişiye dönüp onunla bir göz
göze gelip ona bir gülümseyerek merhaba
der misiniz Allah aşkına
şöyle ne güzel yani herhalde böyle bir
gülümseyerek Merhaba dediğimizde hemen
arkasından da şöyle bir gülümseyerek
Merhaba aldığımızda iş daha keyifli hale
gelmeye başlıyor ben ilk kişiyi aynı
bunu niyetle elimi uzattım merhaba dedim
nasılsınız dedim Tabii ki kötüyüz dedi
dedim neden kötüsünüz işte dedi Hocam
dedi sizde de Antalya'dan gelmişsiniz
dedi Burası dedi vurdu dedi vurdu dedi
sosyal imkanlarımız Yok dedi hiç dedi
burada dedi küçük yerde bir şirkette
dedi Şu problemler var bu problemler var
üst üste gelince sorunlar bütün böyle
olumsuzluklar benim içimdeki enerjiyi
çekildi bir anda bassın bu dünya moduna
geçtim tamam hayatımızın hep Yani
hepimizin hayatında sorunlar var ama üst
üste gelince böyle bir içimdeki enerjiyi
çekildi ikinci kişiye gittim aynı Üçüncü
kişiye gittim aynı
derken firma sahibi dedi ki hocam bir
depo bölümümüz var ya orada kişilerle
tanışmanızı çok isterim
Hadi oraya inelim Tamam dedim inelim Ama
içimden düşündüm Şimdi depo bölümüne
gideceğiz Güneş gören insanlar dedim bu
kadar şikayetçi ise aşağıda dedim kesin
beni frenkeşliler bekliyor
asansörlü aşağı indik asansör kapısı bir
açıldı şöyle bir beyefendi hafif göbekli
55 yaşlarında böyle inanılmaz bir
enerjisi var Denizli şivesinde o Cem
dedi hoş geldin dedi bir sarıldı bana
göbeğin üzerinde bir sağa attırıyor beni
bir sola attırıyor Bir Sağa attırıyor
bir sola attırıyor inanılmaz bir
enerjisi var bıraktı ben hamleteceğim
sana
dedi asansörde dedi Şu yenilikleri
yapacağım dedi falan birisi mutlu bir
mutlu sinir oldum adamı
beyefendi dedim Sizin isminiz ne Kamil
Kamil Bey dedim Siz dedim neden
mutlusunuz
Hocam dedi bu Botanik bahçesinin içinde
de insan değil mutsuz oluyor mu dedi ya
sağa baktım Botanik Bahçesi yok sola
baktım Botanik Bahçesi yok herhalde
düşündüm bizim Kamil Amca'nın tahtası
yok yani
çaylar içildi kahveler içildi güzeldi
sohbet hala coşkulan anlatıyor tam
kalkarken dizilime dokundu Bizim de
Botanik bahçesini gömeceğim dedi Hadi
dedim göster böyle köşeye götürdü beni
Gün Işığı vuran bir bölgeye 7 tane Ekip
arkadaşlarıyla birlikte saksı çiçeğe
koymuşlar Hocam dedi Her bebeğimizin
dedi çocuklara isimleri vardı burada
Ellerinden öper dedi iki tane kıza
evladım vaat dedi okuyacakları inşallah
dedi Her gün dedi bu çiçekle Vaka Vaka
dedi Neden bu da olduğumuzu hatırlarız
dedi
çok etkilendim hikayesinden sonrasında
Çok da şeyler öğrendim kendisinden Kamil
amca'dan ama bana öğrettiği şey güçlü
bir nedenim varsa gerçekten hayat
içerisinde böyle karşılaştığın
zorlukları aşabilecek hemen arkasından
umudunu kaybettiğinde seni ayağa
kaldırabilecek de bir İsteğe bir
heyecana sahip oluyorsun ki sahip
olduğun o neden senden daha güçlü büyük
bir amaca hizmet ediyorsa o zaman
yataktan daha istekli kalkmaya
başlıyorsun ki Kamil amcanın nedeni
güçlü bir neden kız çocuklarının
okuduğunu düşünmek Onların her bir
tanesinin Türkan Saylan her bir
tanesinin Betül Mardin olacağını
düşünmek düşündükçe güç verir insana
sizi bir beyefendi ile tanıştırmak
isterim şöyle uzun uzun birazcık
fotoğrafını incelemenizi rica edeceğim
içinden Birçok yerde soruyorum Acaba ne
iş yapıyor olabilir diye hocam özgüvene
bakılırsa kendisi yöneticidir hocam
kooperatif başkanıdır diyenler çok
oluyor kendisi Kandıra'da Kocaeli
Kandıra'da Belki de dünyanın en zor yani
işlerinden bir tanesi kendisi Ee ama
ama hikayesi beni şok etkiledi
ne zaman diyor böyle bir şey yapıyorum
mesleğime inancımı kaybettim Mesleğimi
anlamımı kaybettim hayata böyle bir
şeyimi kaybettim inancımı kaybettim O
zaman işte gittim diyor hayatımla ilgili
bir karar aldım o kararı da hayatıma
uyguladığım andan itibaren hayata diyor
bakış açım değişti işime diyor bakış
açım değişti şimdi yine soruyorum
insanlara nasıl bir karar almış
oluyorsun da bu işte gün geliyor 30 kilo
sırtında yük taşımak zorundasın zor bir
iş yapıyorsun ve bir anda hamallık ve
seni sevmeye başlıyorsun çok ilginç
almış olduğu kararıyor ya diyor bu
ülkede diyor birçok insan var okuyamayan
birçok çocuk var okuyamayan yardıma
muhtaç Bir çok çocuk var ya diyor Bir ay
böyle bir çalışsan bir günlük yevmiye mi
diyor Ben diyor Hayır kurumlarına böyle
bir versem bağışta bulunsam ne
kaybederim ki diyor kendi kendine bir
karar veriyor Ben diyor Mehmet Ateş
Bundan sonra her gün diyor çalışacağım
her kaydediyor bir günlük yevmiye ve bir
hayır kurumuna bağışlayacağım bu kararı
uyguladıktan sonra her ay 2017'den beri
bu şeyi hayatında geçiriyor ve bağış
yaptıkça hayatı değişiyor ilk bağışının
Darüşşafaka'ya yapıyor bağış yaptıkça
daha iyi çalışmaya başlıyor bağış
yaptıkça daha istekli çalışmaya başlıyor
röportajındaki Şu sözler beni çok
etkiledi ya diyor Evet diyor Çok zor bir
iş yapıyorum Mesleğimi çok büyük
zorlukları var ne zaman diyor sırtımda
diyor böyle diyor yükler daha çok
çoğalmaya başlıyorsa O diyor okuyacak
olan kız çocuklarını düşünmeye
Başlıyorum o zaman diyor sırtımdaki
yükler yavaş yavaş hafiflemeye başlıyor
klasan mal diyorlar ona Bununla birlikte
şu anda gidiyor okullarda Mehmet Ateş
bu konuda eğitimler ve konferanslar
veriyor hikayenin Bir de bir kahramanı
var Mehmet Ateş'in darüşşafakaya'ya
yaptığı bağışlarla okuyan ve mezun olan
bir kızımız işe başlıyor ilk maaşı ile
Mehmet abisini unutmuyor ona gidiyor
şöyle güzel bir takım elbise alıyor
ondan sonra takım elbiseyi aldıktan
sonra Mehmet Ateş diyor ki bu diyor
hayatında aldığım en anlamlı hediye
Geçenlerde Telefonda konuştum kendisiyle
gençlere çok örnek olan bir insan
Kandıra'da ve Öyle de bir kartviziti var
ki kart dizisinde de şu yazıyor beni çok
etkiledi her türlü legal ve güç
gerektiren iş itina ile yapılır diyor
Bir şeye sahip olmak değil bir şeye
layık olmanın belki en güzel
örneklerinden bir tanesi erik kurum bu
sözünü çok seviyorum Benim hikayeme de
birazcık baktığımızda hikayemde arka
planda annem babam aynı zamanda dedem
var Dedem köyün sünnetli öğretmen Annem
öğretmen Babam öğretmen 9 yaşına kadar
dedemin yanındayım sağ olsun kendisinden
böyle tarım Toprak müzik konusunda
birçok eğitim aldıktan sonra onun eğitim
hikayeleriyle büyüdüm köy okulunda
yaptıklarıyla şu anda dedim eğitmenlik
yapıyorum o hikayeleri açıkçası bana
kılavuzluk yapıyor
hayatın bir sosyal sorumluluk projesiyle
değişti eğitmenliği başlangıç
yolculuğunun altında Çocuk Esirgeme
kurumlarında cezaevlerinde köy
okullarında gönüllü eğitimler ve
Seminerler verdiğimiz bir sosyal
sorumluluk projesi içerisinde yer aldım
eğitmenlik yaptım ve bu sosyal
sorumluluk projesi ile hayatıma bir
neden kalktım O da bilginin zekatını
vermek Ancak her Yeni Başlangıç gibi
benim eğitmenlik başlangıcımda kolay
olmadı İlk seminerimi hatırlıyorum yani
Çocuklara bir şey anlatmak kolay değil
bir köy okulundayım 40 tane 50 tane
böyle köy okulundan öğrenci var küçük
çocuklar karşılarına geçtim şöyle
özgüvenle dedim ki kazların dedim
uçuşunu hiç gözlemlediğiniz mi
bir tane ise elini kaldırdı dedi Sen
gözlemledim mi
abi sahnede bir düşündün gözlemlemişim
döndüm geriye yeni başlangıç için o
zaman yani böyle daha çok çalışmanın
daha çok okumanın daha çok gözlem
yapmanın farkına vardım eğitmenlik
yolculuğu ile ilgili işte tamam oku ama
bir tarafta da Üzerimde çok büyük emeğe
olan bir kişi var adı Erhan Özal ile
emekli ay kendisiyle eğitmenliğin
başında tanıştım bir toplantıda çok sert
de bir mizacı var ama çok Analitik bir
insan şurada bir nokta olsun kimse Böyle
göremez o görür o yakalar ya dedim
eğitmenliğin başlangıcında ben bu
insanlar çok iyi geri bildirimler alırım
Erhan Bey dedim Öyle Arada sırada
seminerlerime gelip böyle bir gözlem
yapsanız bana geri bildirim verseniz çok
güzel olur dedim gelir misiniz Emin
misin dedi
çok şey kazandırırsınız ne zaman dedi
Senin ilk seminerin haftaya dedim
Akdeniz Üniversitesi Salı günü 3 saatlik
programı var gelir misiniz dedim gelirim
dedi
Salona geçtim 15 dakika var 150-200 kişi
gelecek öğrenci gelecek ama 15 dakika
kala içeriye bir girdi Ne yaptım ben
dedim ya Yani koltuğun altında böyle
dosyalar kağıtlar içeri bir girişi var
oytuncum Nerede durayım Sen nerede
duracaksın önümde kimse olmaz değil mi
böyle en öne oturdu hazır şu şekilde
bekliyor
sahneye bir çıkışım var
hoş geldiniz dedim Eren Bey ile göz göze
geldik Eren Bey böyle yaptı
Nasılsınız diyorum not alıyorum Not
alıyorum içimden diyorum ki yine ne
yaptım ben yine ne yaptım ben o semineri
çok zor bitirdim bir saatte böyle bir
kan ter içerisinde kalmışım sonrasında
yanına gittim hocam dedim Ne yaptınız bu
kadar ne not aldığını söyler misiniz
akşam dedi böyle bir temize çekeyim sana
dedi e-posta göndereyim bana akşam bile
e-posta geldi Tam 13 madde
ilk madde de şu pantolonun
ütüsüzdü
şu an benim pantolonum odaklanıyorsunuz
unutmuşuz canı çıktı ikinci madde işte
şöyle şurada her bir saniyesini çok
güzel bir şekilde kaydetmiş o an Can
acıtsa da dedim ki ya yeni başlangıçlar
için geri bildirimleri ne kadar kıymetli
olduğunu da kendisinden Anladım
eğitmenlik yolculuk şu an 10 senedir
devam ediyor çeşitli kurumlara gidiyorum
öğreniyorum aynı zamanda ama işimiz şu
anda çok kolay bu dönem
de bir olay işte Hiç olmadı böyle bir
çevrimiçi tak tıklıyoruz istediğimiz
noktaya ulaşıyoruz imkanlarımız şu anda
çok iyi ama böyle kutsallara gelirken o
imkanlara sahip olamayan bir kişiyle
sizlere tanıtmadan gitmek istemedim adım
Mustafa güzelgöz aranızda tanıyanlarınız
vardır
Mustafa amcanın tarihini 1950'li
yıllarda Ürgüp'teki Tahsin'e ait
kütüphanesine çıkıyor genç Mustafa işini
çok seviyor Bununla birlikte ilk gün
açıyor Kimse gelmiyor kütüphaneye ikinci
gün kütüphaneyi açıyor akşama kadar
bekliyor Kimse gelmiyor 3 gün kimse
gelmiyor sonra diyor ki ya bu iş böyle
olmaz Ben diyor aldığım parayı hak
etmiyorum Ne yapacaksın gidiyor kendi
maaşıyla şu görmüş olduğunuz eşeği satın
alıyor eşeğin Sağına bir sandık
yaptırıyor Soluna bir sandık yaptırıyor
ağırlıklı olarak çocuk kitapları olmak
üzere dolduruyor sandığın içine eşeğin
adı da Yüksel yükselle başlıyor ürgüp'ün
köylerini dolaşmaya
insanlar köylüler görünce Şaşkın Sen
kimsin Ben işte Tahsin ağ
kütüphanesinden geldim Siz gelmediniz
Ben sizin ayağınıza geldim okuyun Bu
kitapları çocuklarınıza okutun diyor
insanlar böyle bir şaşırıyorlar ikinci
gün onlarca kilometre yol yürüyen bir
insan köye geldikçe Artık yavaş yavaş ne
yapmaya başlıyorlar Mustafa amcayı
tanıdıkça seviyorlar her gelişinde artık
gözlemeler ayranlar yapılmaya başlıyor
çocuklar eşekli kütüphaneci diye
çağırıyorlar Mustafa amcayı Ve İnsanlar
kitap okumaya başlıyorlar sevdikçe
Mustafa amca kütüphanesine gitmeye
başlıyorlar aradan geçmiş Belki de 3-4
ay Mustafa amca kütüphaneye bir bakıyor
İçerisi insan dolu
o an dünyanın en mutlu insanlarından bir
tanesi ama bir de bir derdi var Çünkü
şöyle dikkatli bakınca hep erkek içeride
hiçbir kadın yok bunu dert ediniyor ya
diyor kadının okuması lazım Çünkü kadın
okursa çocuğuna okutur ne yaparım Ne
ederim bunu dert ediniyor kendisine
kadınları kütüphaneye şekerim diye
Gecelerce uykusuz kalıyor Oytun Nereden
biliyorsun uykusuz kaldığını pandemi
döneminde oğlu Murat güzel gözle
tanıştım o anlattı Hocam dedi 3 gün
uykusuz 4 gün uykusuz kadınları
kütüphaneye çekmek için Sürekli fikir
düşünüyor Bir gece diyor uyurken diyor
babamın diyor Buldum buldum sesiyle
uyandık diyor yanına bir gittik
Ne buldun baba deyince kadınları
kütüphaneye çekmek için diyor ki bu
zamanda diyor bir dikiş makinesi
bulabilirsem ve kütüphanenin içerisine
koyarsam duyan kadardın diyor Hem dikiş
Diker hem de kitap okur fikir Nasıl
fikir çok güzel ama o yokluk dönemde
nereden bulacak oturuyor
Zenit ve singeri O dönemin en ünlü beyaz
eşya markaları oturuyor o gece mektup
yazıyor ya diyor Burası diyor çok faal
bir kütüphane buraya Herkes geliyor da
kadınlar gelmiyor Siz diyor bana diyor
bir dikiş makinesi hediye eder misiniz
hediye ederseniz de diyor Ben de diyor
yaptığınız Bu iyiliği karşılıksız
bırakmam kapıyı diyor firmanızın
logolarını asarım kütüphanenin Kapısına
Belki de Türkiye'nin ilk sponsorluk
faaliyeti Ziynet ve süngerin o kadar çok
hoşuna gidiyor ki bir mektup seni tam 9
tane Singer bir tane dikiş makinesini
mustafa amcaya gönderiyorlar Mustafa
amca yerleştiriyor içeriye duyan kadın
koşuyor kütüphaneye Herkes kötü Fani
yine bir terslik var içeride 10 tane
dikiş makinesi var 40 kadın sıra
bekliyor bizim Mustafa amca böyle
bekleyen sıra bekleyen kadınların yanına
gidiyor
sıra Beklerken kitap okuyun
kadınlara da kitap kokusunu aldırıyor ve
kadınlarda artık o bölgede O kütüphanede
okuma alışkanlığı kazanıyor
Tabii ki Mustafa amcanın yaptığı bu
imkansızlıklar karşısındaki tüm
faaliyetler karşılıksız kalmıyor 1963
yılında Uluslararası bir yarışma
düzenleniyor Devlet Planlama Teşkilatı
Mustafa güzelgöz'ün yaptıklarını
projelenleri Bu yarışmaya gönderiyor
ünlü yarışma Mustafa güzelgöz tam 77
ülkeyi Geride bırakıp birinci oluyor
Dünya Barış Gönüllüleri insanlığa hizmet
ödülünü Amerika devlet başkanı
kennedy'nin elinden alıyor bu ülkeye
kazandırıyor
niteliyor ki bir nedeni olan her nasılla
bir şekilde katlanır
başlangıçta Picasso'nun güvenlik a
tablosundan bahsetmiştim dönelim
güvenlik a tablosuna yıl 1937 yer
İspanya bir İspanyol Kasabası olan
güvenlika bir pazar günü halk masum bir
şekilde pazarda alışveriş yaparken Nazi
uçakları tarafından bombalanıyor
yaklaşık 1700 kişi bu saldırıda hayatını
kaybediyor bu saldırıdan en çok
etkilenen isimlerden bir tanesi de
Picasso ve bir tablo çizip Bu tabloyu
İspanyol halkına hediye etmeyi bir borç
biliyor ortaya dünyanın en önemli Savaş
karşısı tablolarından bir tanesi olan
güvenlik açıyor Hatta
1940 yılında bir Alman General
Picasso'nun sergisini gezerken
Picasso'nun yanına gidiyor diyor ki bu
tabloyu diyor siz mi yaptınız Picasso
eğilip hemen diyor ki hayır diyor bu
tabloyu
Biz yaptınız
Bugün de dışarıda böyle bir değişik bir
tablomuz var kimimizin böyle umutla
baktı bazılarımızın da umutsuz bir
şekilde baktı bir tablo ile karşı
karşıyayız ancak bir tabloyu izlerken de
iki farklı şekilde izleyebiliriz
Bunlardan birincisi bu tabloya uzun uzun
bakar ya benim bu tabloyla ilgili hiçbir
sorun bulduğum yok Yapacak hiçbir şeyim
yok diyerek o tablonun yanından
uzaklaşıp gidebiliriz ya da bu tabloyu
daha da iyi hale getirmek için neler
yapabilirim acaba ortadaki Bu tablo ile
ilgili benim bir sorumluluğum var mı
diyerek böyle küçük küçük adımlar
atabiliriz Tıpkı
Bu ülkenin her sene Kıbrıs kadar
toprağını erozyonda kaybetmesini
kendisine dert edinip kurmuş olduğu TEMA
Vakfı bünyesinde bu ülkeyi karış karış
dolaşarak milyonlarca meşe Pala olduğunu
bu ülkeye kazandıran Hayrettin Karaca
gibi
1900'lü yılların başında kadınların
fakültelerde eğitim görmesi görememesini
yasak olmasını kendisine dert edinerek
ya ben bu ülkenin ilk kadın avukatı
olacağım diyerek yola çıkan
karşılaştıkları tüm engelleri teker
teker Aşan ve bu ülkenin ilk kadın
avukatı olan Süreyya Ağaoğlu gibi Ne de
olsa Umutsuz durum yok Umutsuz insanlar
var sadece o umudu birazcık
yeşertebilmek için ve güçlü nedenleri
ihtiyaç var Çok teşekkür ediyorum Çok
sağ ol